you certainly dis young didn't miss your
moment when they were casting The
Aviator now obviously that was a very
attractive project you had the
opportunity to be directed by Martin
Scorsese to star with Leonardo DiCaprio
using that project as an example how do
you avoid the factor of intimidation
expectation and pressure of that kind of
situation I think because the challenge
was so big and I knew I could but
disappoint legions of Hepburn fans then
you just have to throw caution to the
wind really and know that you're gonna
screw up but Scorsese you're in Uranus
Scorsese's film first and foremost and
he did the most generous wonderful thing
when when we sat down to we talked
obviously remotely but when we sat down
to talk about it cuz he filmed a large
part of it in Montreal and they'd
already been filming for several weeks
by the time I got there and he just said
look you know she was a redhead you'd be
you don't you you look great blonde you
just be blonde you know doesn't matter
you don't know she was there my about it
you can miss skirt he but he was
basically saying to me it doesn't I'm it
doesn't matter you can go as close as
you possibly can or not so you had a
freedom yeah enormous freedom but he
took that pressure off me straight away
but what he did do which was genius is
he he set a list of films made at peace
screened them of course because he would
never have you watched them any other
way but he screened a whole lot of films
for me and what I realized was he was
interested in a certain attack and a
certain rhythm that know obviously
Philadelphia's story but bringing up
baby and and that there was a rhythm and
an attack and a physicality to to the
Hepburn that you know and also films
that she wasn't in but dialogue delivery
and if you've seen the film the very
first scene that I'm in she just talks
non-stop and just got and so I I had a
sense of the the rhythmic approach to it
which in you never know where a
character is going to spring from it can
be it can be from from from a rhythm
after Elizabeth II took on another regal
role in Lord
the Rings now why did you want to be
part of that franchise and did you
always have the faith that it was going
to be quite as impactful as it became I
didn't really care Tippett to be honest
I wanted to work with Peter Jackson you
know brain-dead and I mean all the
zombie stuff that he and Fran had done I
loved some beasts and so that really
interested me and he's got this intense
sense of the ugly which I thought would
be really interesting to bring out in
Tolkien's work so it was the endeavor
that interested me I had no idea that it
was going to be what it was I guess
somebody did they need Peter a friend
but you love zombies is that a role you
long to take on in the future I think
probably the zombie moment is past but
yeah maybe miss the moment there I
missed the vampire moment I'm always
behind the eight-ball well you certainly
didn't miss yours Obie musical maybe oh
well there you go
zombie comedy although they've already
done that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]